Sáng 18, Xuức dầu bắt đầu phía in sui đại hội đại biểu tòan khúc lên thứ 14 của đàn cộ sân Việt Nam.
Các liền đạo đàn nhấn nước và đại biểu dự đại hội vào lăng viễn chủ tình của chimêng.
Lặt vào hoa trước đại tình miệng các ai hùng lật xế.
Đó đại biểu có tổ Mỹ thư tô lâm, các quý viên bộ chiến chi, chủ tình nước lớn cơng,
thủ tướng trịt phủ phạm mi trếng, chủ tịch của hội trình thánh bánh,
thương trực bán bị thư trình cầm tố, không thăm dự có khác quý viên bộ chiến chi,
quý viên bánh bị thư, quý viên chu injustice đàn các bạn biểu dự đại hội bị bốn của đàn.
Châu khú khi chăng nghiêm xúc đậu đoàn tại biểu tới thành kính dân qua,
mấy tò lòng bi đường xấu rất đối với chủ tỉnh hội chimêng.
Người sáng lập và dân liển đàn cộ sản Việt Nam,
lạnh tổ vì đại của dân tòp Việt Nam,
vòng qua của đoàn mặng dổngs với lời dời dưới dưới nhớ hơn chủ tỉnh hội chimêng bị đại.
Tr Impf đó đoàn tại biểu đại đến đại vòng qua,
rất vương tại đại tưởng miệng cả hành hục lịch sĩ trên đường bắt sơn hà nội.
Các bạn bây giờ nghe mình tưởng nhớ những người còn yêu tủ của giân tộc.
Đại hình xin nghe dụng vì được lập tự gió và thông nhé đơn nước.
Hó đậu mang yên giề chính trị tình thân sâu sắc,
thì hệ nha đào lý uống nước nướng nướng nguồn,
đồng thời khẳng định quyết tâm của toàn đạn,
toàn dân khi bước con đường kết mạng mà đạn,
mắc vô và các thị hệ trái đã lựa cho.
Sau khi vào lăng viễn chủ tình hồ chiming,
và rất hương tại đại tưởng miệng cả hành miệng sĩ,
tại hộ mình bốn của đạn hất đồng ngày làm việc tinh nhất,
với sự tham dự của một nghiên năm trăm tâm y sảo đại biểu.
Đại diện cho hơn năm triệu đảng viên cho cả nước.